les russes se prépare à bombarder le
port ukrainien d'odessa c'est une
déclaration du président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky bruno daroux merci
d'être avec nous allanon capitulation le
fait qu'il s'exprime largement le
président ukrainien via des vidéos et
via internet est-ce que la non
capitulation du gouvernement ukrainien
pose et va poser un problème politique
majeur à vladimir poutine ah oui ça pose
un problème à vladimir poutine tout
simplement parce que c'est un des deux
objectifs officiels qu'il a énoncées
pour justifier son agression contre
l'ukraine puisqu'il y avait la
démilitarisation de l'armée ukrainienne
d'un côté ça c'est l'objectif plus
militaire on va dire et puis ce qu'il
appelle la dénazification
du régime ukrainien donc il considère
que volodymyr zelensky et son entourage
sont des nazis et que donc il faut que
l'ukraine change de régime politique et
de ce point de vue là on sait que
l'opération sur kiev a été décidée
grandement pour atteindre cet objectif
c'est-à-dire nos pense-t-on s'emparer
d'eux hélène ce qui est installé à sa
place 1 j me fantoches il se dit que
l'ancien président ianoukovitch proche
de moscou serait à minsk en attente de
faire le voyage à kiev si c'est
évidemment le régime zelensky tombe mais
on en n'est pas là parce que depuis dix
jours maintenant et bien zelensky il le
il tient bon non seulement il tient bon
mais il a une politique de communication
qui apparaît quand même très efficace et
très pertinente politique très moderne
sur les réseaux sociaux il arrive c'est
ça qui est étonnant quand même parce que
on imagine qu'il ya des forces spéciales
russes dans kiev il arrive en fait en
tout cas ne pas se faire trop localiser
le bouge beaucoup il a même réussi à
faire une conférence de presse avec des
journalistes donc oui c'est un problème
important pour pour vladimir poutine
parce que lui clairement ne peut pas
continuer avec ce régime même si tout ce
que fait vladimir poutine il faut quand
même le dire au passage relève de
l'illégalité 1 il n'a pas déclaré la
guerre à l'ukraine en bonne et due forme
ce qu'il estime usé une opération
militaire spéciale sans doute dans une
province normalement il aurait dû
déclarer la guerre il ne l'a pas fait et
il décide que ce régime n'est pas bon
pour le pays donc en violation totale de
la souveraineté de ce pays quelle est
l'importance là le président soehnlen ce
qu'ils déclarent que il s'apprête à
bombarder la ville d'odessa qui donc est
au bord de la mer noire stratégiques
qu'elles sont importants dit oui alors
au dessin évidemment c'est stratégique
d'abord parce que c'est la troisième
ville du pays donc c'est une ville très
importantes qu'elle est donc au sud de
l'ukraine mais qu' elle constituerait si
vous voulez le la terminaison si j'ose
dire de cette reconquête effectué par
les russes le long des côtes ukrainienne
au sud et évidemment ça permettrait même
éventuellement de faire la jonction avec
la transnistrie
voisine qui est donc une province pro
russe de moldavie cette fois donc
appartenant à un autre état et
évidemment symboliquement ce serait la
troisième ville du pays qui tomberait
entre les mains des russes ce serait la
plus grosse prise des russes on n'en est
pas là encore hélène ce qui annonce que
des bombardements vont commencer contre
au dessin avant ça il ya aussi le sort
de kharkiv qui est la deuxième ville qui
est la deuxième ville du pays aux normes
et en termes d'importance je dis au
revoir à dia kiev numéro un kharkiv
numéro deux au dessin numéro trois après
évidemment mario paul vi est un verrou
stratégique très important merci
beaucoup bruno daroux pour votre
décryptage merci à vous